it is interesting seeing the way that
like the fact that there's any
competition at all kind of proves that
if you're not paying close attention you
wonder how that could possibly be
because if you're not paying close
attention you just assume he's doing a
great job you don't know what's actually
going on in the world but if there's any
competition at all it does prove that
there is a bit of a dent in the armor
there and it's hard for the average
person to see but just even hearing
about an RFK if you're somebody that
doesn't pay close attention to politics
I would hope that would at least wake
them up and be like why is there anyone
even questioning this at all you could
actually I guess mention his age would
be a big part of it like a lot of people
even if they're not politically uh
initiated might wonder why is the guy
his age going to be running again
Trump's Trump's fairly old as well yeah
what what is what is 75 years younger
than bite and he just doesn't show it no
way he's more than these years yeah yeah
he's four years four or five four five
he will be the same age like he would
have been the same age at the next
election that Biden was when he got
elected